-Now, Ewan,
you star in the new movie
"Birds of Prey,"
but, a lot of people might not
know that, back in the '80s,
we were actually
on a show together.
-You're talking
about "Point Pleasant."
-You remember that?
-Of course. Yeah, yeah.
-That's right.
The show was called
"Point Pleasant
Police Department"
and it took place in lovely
Point Pleasant, New Jersey.
-Right.
[ Cheering ]
-We played two detectives
who couldn't see eye-to-eye
and we'd get in a lotta
arguments and, yeah.
-I mean, I know it sounds
like we're jokin' around,
but it was really quite
intense drama.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
-Intense show.
-The two cops would get
in a lot of arguments
and always seemed to end up
[laughing] in messy situations.
We actually have a clip
from one of the episodes.
-No, you do not.
-I do, yeah.
-You do?
-Take a look.
[ Upbeat rock plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Well, what's poppin', Palmer?
-Not much, Pete.
You seem pretty, uh,
perturbed.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
-Probably 'cause
Lieutenant Porter
put me on probation.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah!
All this shall pass, eh, Pete?
[ Laughter ]
-I repeat --
[ Laughing ]
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Sputtering ]
[ Fresh laughter and applause ]
Let's have a party
in the Point Pleasant
Police Department, come on!
-Okay.
-Kaplew!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Xavier?
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[Laughing]
You know, watching it --
watching it
was even more intense
than I remember.
-Yeah. It's really -- It was
really in-your-face stuff.
-[laughing] Oh! We actually
have another clip.
-No!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Where?
-That was the blooper episode.
-Ah.
We actually --
-You got the real deal.
-We broke and it was
like ridiculous.
Never aired,
so that was a little treat.
But we have another clip.
[ Laughter ]
In this episode, I think
I have more lines than you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clapping ]
Let's take a look at this.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and cheer ]
-You're late, Palmer!
[ Laughter ]
Problems parking?
-Precisely.
Some punk parked his Prius
in my...place!
[ Laughter ]
-That peeves my pickle!
That's right.
-I prefer the --
I prefer the pamplemousse.
-Oh, yeah?
-Pamplemousse!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
-Pamplemousse?
Why don't you try punch?
[ Laughter ]
-Only if you pass the puddin'.
-Well, then --
[ Laughter ]
-Pudding!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ah, puddin' me!
Ah, puddin'!
-That one hurt.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, that was like
a rock, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You don't want any parfait?
-I like puddin'!
How many times
I gotta tell you?
Puddin'!
-Parfait!
[ Laughter ]
-Puddin'!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Good clip.
You can --
[ Laughing helplessly ]
You can really feel
the emotion in that scene.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Even after all these years,
I can almost taste it.
-Yeah?
[ Laughter and applause ]
What's that?
We have one more clip?
-No.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
We have one more clip.
[ Laughter ]
I put this on to remember.
-Oh, just to remind yourself.
-I didn't see --
You didn't recognize it.
You didn't see it.
[ Laughter ]
We really have one more clip?
Alright, man.
This one, [laughs]
the tension really comes
to a boil
and things get outta control.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, in this one?
-In this one, yeah.
Check it out.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
-Proud of ya, Pete!
[ Laughter ]
The way you pinpointed
Point Pleasant's
most prolific predator.
Are you pleased?
-I'm more peppy
than a porcupine in a puddle.
-Pardon the pun,
but perhaps we should
pig out!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Well.
-What do you think?
[ Laughter ]
-Perhaps some pecan pie!
-Ah!
No, I prefer the peach pie!
[ Laughter ]
-How about
pomegranate pie?!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Pretty good, Pete.
-Yeah, thanks.
-Yeah, but there's
an important piece missin'
to this pie puzzle.
-Yeah, what's that?
[ Laughter ]
[ Hissing ]
-Oh. Hang on.
-Yeah.
-[Mumbling]
[ Laughter ]
No. Oh, you're gettin' high.
He's getting -- no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
No.
-Perfect.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect!
-Well put, partner.
I'm glad we took part
in the Point Pleasant
Police Department.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
♪♪
-What a show.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Wow.
What a show!
-What a show.
[ Laughter ]
-What a show that was.
-Wow.
They should bring it back.
-They should bring it back.
My thanks to Ewan McGregor,
everyone.